temos alguma dificuldade em saber ao
certo há quanto tempo acredito mundo
como nós vemos existe
nós sabemos que o ser humano anda a
passear nesta linha azul a mais ou menos
57 milhões de anos
imagino eu que desde o início as pessoas
tenham questionado o que está certo e
quem está errado em andamento o
comportamento entre pessoas do nosso
banco os valores moral e ética
acredito também que nesse sentido mais
ou menos nos últimos três mil anos os
grandes regiões tentaram de alguma forma
nos organizar os segurados para nos
proteger e fazer mal a nós próprios e
curioso vemos que a sociedade civil
só há cerca de 70 anos é que se deu por
escrito por tudo aquilo que interessa na
vida tentar escrito algo para nos ajudar
orientar sobre o que está certo eo que
está errado isso isso a declaração
universal dos direitos humanos
não é difícil esperem pelo meu currículo
em termos de emissões
já passei por muitos países
provavelmente as maiores catástrofes
humanitárias dos dias de hoje
nesta questão dos direitos humanos ainda
em demora estará cimentada exemplo que
está mais próximo até porque foi mais
ameaçado as três chamadas câmeras sair
do iml
é isso que é catalogado como a pior
crise humanitária dos últimos 100 anos
alguns números não só pelas
conseqüências diretas do conflito mas
acima de tudo pelas conseqüências
indiretas são absolutamente assustador
dizem que 84 mil crianças dos outros
quatro anos já morreram à fome não
costuma ser uma disso uma doença muito
difícil tratar a forma e cerca de 5
milhões de crianças estão em risco de
morrer à fome
só no iêmen em seu estado o ano passado
2.018 foram declarados
agora com um milhão de pessoas afetadas
até que ponto é que está entrando nas
nossas vidas até que ponto é que isto
foi notícia que nos incomodou nos
preocupamos
mas o porquê destas coisas qual é o
problema
bruna máxima todos somos nós porque nós
empate enquanto seres humanos é muito
seletiva dentro da corda da raça da
religião das leis que nós falamos não
compreendemos
temos também é absolutamente
desumanizados quando começamos a falar
de números isso que sempre estamos a
falar pessoas é eu acho que nós
portugueses no campo da desonestidade
histórica são provavelmente os maiores
do mundo chamados uma grande coisa de
descobrimentos quando no fundo nós
matamos viu após roubar nos escravizamos
trafegamos pessoas fomos os primeiros
somos os últimos e foi um dos maiores em
cima dos descobrimentos
somos indiferentes 11 justos e somos
intolerantes relação a quase tudo que
ele fez e nós então qual é a solução
para onde é que nós nos devemos analisar
como eu estava na república democrática
do congo esse cara relativamente pouco
tempo e enquanto não exista estava a
fazer uma cesariana e sair a criança da
barreira mãe e o processo muito
rapidamente que ela estava com o fred
estava mal estava às portas da morte
e cabe a mim estará reanimá la é muito
difícil animar uma criança é assim
pequenina mas acontece nos nossos dias
na nossa sina dos ricos muito poucas
vezes e estou eu com pessoas cardíacas
ventilações adrenalina são minutos que
parecem horas presa em dias muito
intenso e quando finalmente finalmente
criancinha estava recém nascido estava
em que vai instalar o lado está a cuidar
da saúde destinada a salvar 50 para
baixo está a ver tudo é que o que estava
a fazer ao seu filho e o próximo e ela
faz um sinal de que quer dar a mão
muito obrigado
eu fiquei naquele momento
parsay que o mundo era a coisa mais
bonita e e percebi que afinal se
analisarmos não é nossa vontade ser flex
na ajuda aos outros
conseguimos rapidamente responder às
nossas grandes questões
sentimos melhor comigo conosco mesmo e
ao mesmo tempo estamos a criar algo
maior
a república centro africana em um país
desconhecido para a maioria das pessoas
e que está conta também com uma das
piores guerras dos nossos dias
pela dimensão pelo espectro de violência
pela pela duração que prevê quase
infinita e eu acho que é ser tudo
recursos humanos escalada teve vontades
políticas para resolver este conflito e
eu terminar na altura estava numa terra
da rainha
se algo não vai bem na vida terrestre
que já tenha sido varrida pelo conflito
trás para frente por diferentes grupos
armados
capitu o espectro da violência então se
dava edifício tempo porém palavras
determinada altura e cruzando com uma
missão católica
o hospital tem uma escola e outros
outros projetos de desenvolvimento e
estava sentado na cozinha porque
obviamente que as atrações atenções
foram atraídas por que era porque deram
comida para falar com uma irmã que era
uma das responsáveis por esta missão
católica literalmente no meio do nada e
perguntar-lhes irmã daniela qual é o
vosso plano de evacuação quando as
coisas complicam quando isso acontece um
carinho assim pra mim era italiana não
francês com sotaque italiano dovizioso e
mesmo assim quanto mais difícil isto
fica mas é preciso nós o mais importante
é o nosso trabalho
nós nunca vamos embora e eu estava na
cintura especial porque estava lá há
três ou quatro meses no país unama
precisa de muita chuva e este mau estava
lá há 30 anos e um banho de humildade e
e se matou
um banho de inspiração e norma eu acho
que nós vivemos inspirados
é melhor usar viva nós podemos ter nas
nossas vidas escolher novamente as
suspensões certas e premiarmos a vondade
e tentarmos ir atrás dela ouvindo muitas
vezes que o problema são os políticos só
aos 6 que não nos dizem o contrário os
mal fazem errado
o plano nosso melzi população somos nós
porque vivemos numa democracia
facilmente precisamos que tanto os
políticos como os media não são livres
sofredores nós mostrarmos para nós é
mais importante é pressão da vida humana
aquém e além fronteiras do que tantas
outras coisas as notícias vão ser dadas
as decisões vão ser tomadas em
conformidade e vamos obviamente a
caminhar para algo melhor
o prédio conta a quantidade de vidas que
o poder nas mãos do iêmen na quantidade
de famílias inteiras para os braços
padrão as pernas
vejo muito tristes das consequências do
conflito mas é uma história que marcou
em particular esta rapariga aparece no
serviço de urgência estava jornal ás
ficar lá em prelada se alimentar estava
no esôfago e para aquela situação eu
pensar aí
bom eu sendo a sexta com facilidade nos
desviar com facilidade de observar
diretamente na via aérea e os alfa
esquentar e assim foi tudo uma delas
porque o pai que queria fazer disse que
ela já não comer não devia nada há 24
horas
não sabia o que fazer e eu fiz uma coisa
que chama de golpe há que ter uma coisa
pela garganta dentro e em abrir o campo
de visão direto para atacar e também
para o esôfago e consegui ver o placar e
fez um esforço enorme sim para com uma
pinça tentar de alguma forma puxá-lo
empurrá lo
cheguei mesmo a tocar nela e essa cara
senão micro passo só que não consegui e
explicar isso
provavelmente você terá que fazer uma
endoscopia sua filha já se não tem
dinheiro muito menos com transporte
quanto menos para o atendimento
hospitalar
eu posso fazer algo tão diferenciada e
fui pra casa completamente destruído
o dia será apenas mais uma criança que
morreram e na sé que ela estava ali à
frente e eu tive quase quase quase a
conseguir e no entanto foi destruído
destroçado frustrado mas vamos também o
procedimento que o senhor dentro de mim
depois de tanta coisa que eu já vi
depois de tanta coisa que eu já vivi de
alguma forma sempre bem estar triste por
estar chateado porque sente que ainda
consigo pensar com o coração e acho que
as coisas mais importantes é que nós
nunca devemos perder a vida devemos
cultivar ao máximo e tomar as decisões
mais importantes das nossas vidas
o nosso coração da república democrática
do congo
este tipo de casos kleenex são os
tratamentos frequentes
esta mulher determinada altura parece
nosso hospital
e eu pergunto a informar o congresso
aconteceu um tiro eu pois essa parte eu
já percebi mas porque ela existiu
existiu aqui a violação então então era
um tiro e viu lá eu penso que as pessoas
não têm noção da dimensão desta
problemática da violência sexual em
alguns países a república democrática do
congo é sem dúvida o ponto máximo
centenas de milhares de mulheres já
foram de alguma forma vítimas de
violência sexual ao ponto que o deputado
prêmio nobel da paz deste ano passou
também por um médico indicado esta causa
é curá las e tamanho falar em nome delas
que o que eu penso como é que é possível
os homens que infligem este crime as
mulheres têm tanta maldade mas claro
isso não é questão mais difícil
responder àqueles que tomam as grandes
decisões
como é que conseguem ter tanta maldade
do desprezo pelas vidas humanas e branco
o seu sofrimento
mas eu penso também como é que as
mulheres que estão com esses homens
conseguem ter tanta maldade
quem é mulher que acha que o cuidado fez
bonito quem é mulher que bate palmas o
funcionário quem é mulher que os órgão
todos os dias na cama do paulo autran
eu acho que as mulheres não têm noção
num mundo infelizmente ainda dominado
pelos homens não têm a noção do poder
que têm nas atitudes nas suas escolhas a
fazer ou não uma moldagem mais positiva
na sociedade façam ver que mal dava e e
ganância não são sexy não durmam com as
pessoas que vendem armas não durmam com
as pessoas que fazem maldade
os dias com mais um pouco na minha vida
na síria há uns anos atrás numa bela
manhã de inverno estava sem casa para ir
trabalhar e ver o motorista seria uma
heresia são bonito de sol
eu disse não não está
eles vão voar e assim foi passado modo
estamos nós a trabalhar no hospital e
começamos ouvir o barulho dos aviões que
é absolutamente ineficiente sentir-se
sobrevoado center subtância lavo não
saber se é que eu via que o piloto vai
carregar no botão vermelho em cima das
nossas cabeças só porque sim
e começamos a ouvir
já dentro do banco escondidos de alguma
forma para minimizar os riscos
nós vamos ouvir as bombas aqui e
relativamente longe
conseguimos perceber mais ou menos pela
intensidade do barulho das bombas aqui o
tempo vamos demorar a receber os feridos
em nosso hospital
10 15 minutos o hospital é completamente
inundava os freios por seus
acompanhantes
é um espetáculo bastante difícil de
digerir adianta sofrer aos gritos a
hipótese de aguentar da ar mas
felizmente o fato não compreender a
língua proteger de alguma forma e ajudam
a pensar essencialmente como médico tem
algumas características cascalhar inatas
de boa gestão dos momentos difíceis eu
sou uma máquina é pensar o que nós vamos
fazer é a decisão mais difícil é
primeira classe de nome temos que tomar
quem são os doentes que nós vamos deixar
morrer eu digo vamos deixar morrer e eu
tenho que sobreviver essa decisão tem
que sobreviver aos olhares estão a será
francamente acusatórios mas eu tenho que
ser firma e tem que pensar no todo e
comércio responsável naquela altura
recuperou tomar as decisões difíceis e
esse aí é que nós operamos em primeira
linha que não podem esperar né
nas primeiras horas por uma cirurgia e
depois ficamos a noite toda pra área e
muitas vezes que depois num uma
catástrofe dessas dimensões e
aprendizagem que o tiro de instituições
que infelizmente já tem muitas no meu
currículo é que esta triagem que tem que
ser feita exatamente aquilo que nós
temos que fazer a nossa vida quando
pensamos na humanidade como pensar em
fazer o melhor pelo mundo quer fazer o
máximo o maior número de pessoas
eu acho que o rapidamente nos esquecemos
aquilo que aconteceu no norte do iraque
há uns anos atrás de alguma forma em que
está a acontecer
o estado islâmico possibilidade nosso
que é a segunda cidade iraquiana
tirava com mais de 3 mil anos de
história e ocupou durante cerca de três
anos depois houve um período de guerra
de conquista das irá que durou cerca de
nove meses
esta guerra foi sem dúvida a pior da
talha mais intensa mais mortífera mais
cruel mais desumana
todos os outros da nossa história
contemporânea
foram mais de 50 mil pessoas só neste
conflito por esta cidade
mais de dois milhões de deslocados
nesta região do norte do iraque só à
custa do conflito num curtíssimo espaço
de tempo mas outras doenças oportunistas
mas muita gente como a fome e eu antes
de partir em missão
lembrei-me de tentar pôr em prática
alguns a dia e viagem que eu acredito
que clegg comigo a cada missão
humanitária todas as pessoas que
acreditam naquilo que eu faço todas as
pessoas que acreditam que é preciso
enviar ajuda enviar compaixão
então tive que criar um livro que é
exatamente uma compilação de cartas das
diferentes pessoas criam enviar para nós
ou nós obviamente poderia servir para
tantos outros locais do mundo
uma forma de mostrarem o seu sentido
humanidades conectar em um livro não era
ninguém não impede que as bombas caio
mas acho que dados um sentido família um
sentido de pertença e não sei porque
quando se come diversamente escrever
porque achei que devia pensar no
rapazinho que uma vez tratar e vítima de
um de um ataque london desta suicida a
no afeganistão e que e eu fui pra mim
determinante perceber uma coisa que eu
já vi muitas outras crianças quer ver
crianças que não choram enquanto
retirava os telhados das costas
as lágrimas que ir mas eu não chorava e
foi a pensar neste rapazinho que eu
escrevi a carta que agora partilhar com
vocês para a população do nosso elenco
ninguém pode sentir a dor assim como
ninguém pode sentir a perna dos 300
inscritos
mas seria desumano não tentar ajudar no
momento tanto sofrimento para com isto é
disputou e se não conseguir parar e se
não conseguir aliviar a dor ainda a
certeza em ajuda
eu viajo pelas suas lágrimas e mergulho
em fundo nos seus olhos e perguntou
repetidamente a mesma questão
e se fosse eu a achei do teu lugar
serei eu a capacidade de amar e perdoar
como aceitaria eu as tremendas
injustiças a que estaria sujeito não tem
respostas para estas perguntas mas a
minha luta é lembrar todos desde que
todas as vidas são iguais e que minha
vida não é melhor que atua e todas as
lágrimas têm o mesmo peso do fundo do
meu coração acredito nos poderes
infinitos das nossas ações individuais
mas quando parecem insignificantes a
grande escala
uma pessoa pode mudar o mundo
uma pessoa pode mudar a sua família uma
família pode mudar a sua comunidade
uma comunidade pode mudar uma cidade uma
cidade para mudar um país um país vão
mudar um continente em um continente
pode mudar o mundo e se essa pessoa
fosse estou sociedade este super poder
de influenciar toda a tua volta
tito farias com teorias a espalhar o
ódio ea intolerância
o frio se espalhar alegria à sociedade o
amor ea compaixão que lidera não
precisava ter uma inspiração e assim
passar até virar desfrutar das
maravilhas da nossa natureza mas a tua
coragem espírito tão profundamente
creche em mim uma enorme vantagem em
aproximar me sentar ao seu lado ele
certa
tu és forte corajoso estão melhor do que
eu e por isso te agradeço e por isso
prometo ao meu coração vou atribuir essa
inspiração a fortalece no caráter
eu vou atribuir até um outro fogo
temos que ter a capacidade de amar e
perdoar e fizerem parte debaixo do mesmo
teto
temos que entrar bem no fundo todo mal
que algumas coisas nossas vidas
riveros diaz é multiplicar tudo bem que
algumas delas nos foi feito
eu nunca vou deixar e eu nunca vou
desprezar e nunca vou esquecer disse
eu vou estar sempre ao seu lado e não te
esqueças uma pessoa pode mudar o mundo o
teu irmão estava no carona é no prover
cada um e no poder de cada um de nós da
nossa individualidade que parece tão
insignificante mas é tudo que nós temos
uma força enorme cima que nós podemos
fazer a diferença e um desvio e agradeço
a vossa atenção a todas as vias que já
passaram pelas mãos
obrigado
[Aplausos]